[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen liebe zuschauer bei history
live den historischen quartett auf
phoenix 100 jahre 1918 schicksalsjahr
für deutschland und die welt darüber
diskutieren wir heute mit drei
historiker jörn leonhard von der uni
freiburg
welche fehler man von der tu dresden und
gerd krumeich von der uni des vor 100
jahren war der erste weltkrieg noch
nicht ganz zu ende fast 40 staaten waren
an diesem krieg beteiligt rund 60
millionen soldaten standen sich in
diesem ringen gegenüber
was machte diesen krieg so anders als
alles was man bis dahin gekannt hat der
leon hat ich glaube diesen krieg macht
anders dass er als ein konflikt beginnt
der noch sehr viel mit dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert zu tun hat da marschieren
soldaten in den krieg ein mit
pickelhauben in der erwartung dass wird
ein kurzer krieg da wollen sich junge
männer auszeichnen und dann wird es ein
fast fünf jahre währendes globales
ringen nicht nur ein europäischer krieg
ein globaler krieg und der verändert
diese welt komplett ab 1917 ist das ein
krieg der mit revolution sich verbindet
erst in russland dann in vielen anderen
ländern
und er entlässt im grunde genommen
mehrere generationen in eine völlig
veränderte welt darüber wollen wir reden
was überwiegt denn in der bevölkerung in
deutschland zu dieser zeit frau
fehlemann meine was erleichterung dass
der konflikt vorbei waren dass man
verloren hatte vielleicht auch hoffnung
auf die zukunft oder einfach völlige
verwirrung
ja ich würde sagen fast letzteres also
die gesellschaft war tief gespalten es
ist ja bis zuletzt diskutiert worden
zum beispiel zwischen richard dehmel und
käthe kollwitz ob man nicht kämpfen
sollte bis zum letzten also dass die
gesellschaft war gespalten in diejenigen
die gerne einen verständigungsprozess
preis der
der einschränkung deutschland wenn man
so will und andere die eben kämpfen also
quasi den sieg frieden um jeden preis
wollten
und zwischen diesen beiden polen bewegte
sich die deutsche gesellschaft und das
war auch das problem was eben dann
nachher zu so vielen verwerfungen
geführt hat ende acht vor ende 18 und
anfang 19 wurde ja heftig über die
zukunft deutschlands zukunft diskutiert
worüber wurde gestritten er krumeich wie
sollte eine neue nachkriegsordnung
aussehen
es war wenig klar ich muss dazu sagen
dass ganz wenigen deutschen überhaupt
klar war was dieser krieg überhaupt
gewesen war und ich glaube auch dass das
nicht hinreichend gesehen wird bis heute
dass der krieg nicht in deutschland
stattgefunden hatte in keiner weise wenn
man mal 1914 ostpreußen rausnimmt gründe
wussten die deutschen doch 1900 und 18
oft nicht was dann wesen sie hatten mit
siegesmeldungen gehört sie hatten die
todesnachrichten bekommen in familien
die schreckliche nachricht vom tod des
sohnes ist gut dass des vaters sie
hatten hunger und wussten nicht so
richtig warum das war ganz unterschied
zu frankreich beispielsweise wo der
krieg war und wo es drauf ankam den
deutschen raus zu treiben um jeden preis
und ich denke dass wir um diesen
deutschland im ersten weltkrieg und auch
den eindruck der niederlage zu verstehen
überhaupt wirklich bedenken müssen dass
die deutschen ich sag's mal ganz
pointiert nicht wirklich wussten dass
dieser krieg gewesen war hängt es auch
damit zusammen dass ja noch im frühjahr
sommer 1918 so eine gewisse sieges
hoffnung bestand da gab es ja eine
frühjahrsoffensive und in der
öffentlichen meinung herrschte ja lange
fast bis in den herbst die annahme vor
das deutsche heer sei ja eigentlich gar
noch nicht besiegt warum war das so man
kann sogar weiter gehen
das deutsche reich hat im frühjahr 1918
den ersten weltkrieg in osteuropa
gewonnen
der friedensvertrag von presley tusk ist
der sieg frieden den man sich im grunde
genommen dann auch im westen erhofft hat
und das führt in deutschland übrigens
auch in den anderen gesellschaften dazu
dass man jetzt sagt die situation ist
weiterhin offen wir müssen jetzt
durchhalten und dann bekommen wir den
sieg und das ist ganz wichtig der diese
ganzen opfer von 1914 bis ins frühjahr
in den sommer in den herbst 1918
rechtfertigt es ganz stark dieses motiv
nur ein sieg frieden kann eigentlich
diese unglaublichen kriegsopfer
rechtfertigen und demgegenüber stellt
man alles andere zurück in deutschland
aber vor allen dingen auch in frankreich
und in großbritannien geht die zahl der
streiks zurück sie steigt nicht an es
gibt eine zweite mobilisierung die fast
nochmal an motive des sommers 1914
erinnert kleben auch so der französische
premierminister sagt im frühjahr 1918
einen satz in der abgeordnetenkammer in
paris der das sehr gut auf den punkt
bringt er sagt diesen krieg hat gewonnen
der eine viertelstunde länger aushält
das macht sehr klar dieses gefühl die
sache ist offen und wer jetzt in diesem
augenblick eine konzession macht der hat
verloren
aber dann war er dem deutschen kriegs
diktator ludendorff bald klar im sommer
dass der krieg im westen nicht mehr zu
gewinnen war und er verlangt ja fast
flehentlich den waffen stifter denef
anschließend den zivilisten die die
kastanien aus dem feuer holen
später vorwirft war denn diese
sogenannte dolchstoßlegende
in der tat eine lüge oder was sie doch
ein bisschen mehr
es wird seit damals diskutiert es gibt
auch heute historiker die sagen ist
gerade gar keine legende es war eine
glatte lüge und basta ich finde und
immer mehr das denn ganz bisschen doch
daran ist dass zumindest die rechte und
die in der mitte
eine menge gründe hatten zu glauben dass
zumindest etwas dran war
da ist das problem der ganzen deutschen
sprache deshalb nicht auch das wort was
ich durchgesetzt hat legende und nicht
lüge das wort lüge habe ich deutsch
flüge habe ich auch schon in texten von
1918 und 19 massiv gefunden
deutschlands legende hat sich
durchgesetzt und zwar weil schon
irgendwo das gefühl glaube ich
vorgeherrscht hat über die jahrzehnte
hinweg ein bisschen ist was dran wie
eben in legenden legenden haben einen
wahren kern
da wird nur drum herum gemacht legenden
sind keine lügen und deshalb wird man
auch das wort deutschkurs legende auf
dauer nicht ersetzen können was genau
das war waffenstillstand sagten sie
gerade hat bluten dorf gefordert war das
genau der waffenstillstand den die
zivilisten wolken und was sie darunter
verstanden
ich glaube wirklich wenn man die quellen
anguckt der ludendorff hatte sich
vorgestellt hat mich zwar wie man so
blöd sein konnte hat sich vorgestellt
dass man ihn fast totalen krieg wird
sich die weiße fahne hoch nimmt nach der
alt nach dem alten motto die weiße fahne
kommt hoch damit ich die verwundeten weg
bringen kann und ein bisschen pause habe
und dann weiter zu kämpfen das hat er
sich vorgestellt ende september wenn an
der deutsch- oslo ende etwas dran sei
wie herrlich sagt heißt das dann dass
das deutsche kaiserreich nur ein
bisschen länger durchgehalten hätte wie
hdmi so gemeint hat
das ist das problem von gerd grimm als
argument dem ich an der stelle dann auch
wirklich entschieden widersprechen
möchte
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen dem
wissen der historiker von heute und wir
wissen dass das deutsche reich
militärisch den krieg im sommer und
herbst 1918 verloren hatte daran gibt es
keinen daran gibt es für mich jedenfalls
keinen zweifel und nicht würde so auch
die internationale forschung
zusammenfassen die deutschen haben ein
massives problem mit der zahl von
soldaten die getötet werden die man
nicht mehr ersetzen kann
es werden mehr boote zerstört als
nachgebaut werden das könnte man an ganz
vielen bereichen zeigen
aber dieses rückblickende wissen dass
wir als historiker haben muss ich
trennen von der wahrnehmung der
zeitgenossen und in der wahrnehmung der
zeitgenossen war das bewusstsein wie bei
klima so die sache ist knapp aber es
gibt eine möglichkeit durch einen
durchhalten bis zum schluss doch noch
einen sieg zu erreichen
aber damit hast du mir nicht widerspruch
doch damit habe ich dir widersprochen
weil deine interpretation im grunde
genommen zwischen den beiden nicht
unterscheidet sondern dass eine
sozusagen mit dem anderen verbindet und
darin liegt das problem
und das andere problem ist das muss ich
auch sagen das ist ein schmaler grat
wenn man sich ich formuliere das jetzt
bewusst schaaf zum historischen anwalt
derjenigen macht die dann im herbst 1918
und sommer 1919 die politische kultur
der weimarer republik dadurch vergiftet
haben dass sie diese deutschkurs legende
als ein entlastungs negativ sozusagen
erfunden und weiter geprägt haben dass
hindenburg das vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss ausbreitet ist zu
einem einer schweren belastung der
weimarer republik gewesen und er tut das
gegen besseres wissen denn es sind die
militärs die die zivile reichs leitung
in kenntnis davon setzen dass der krieg
militärisch nicht mehr zu gewinnen ist
weg und wir können darauf antworten und
sie mögen es ja beim nissan juke am 5 ja
richtig kontakt um wirklich darum
streiten und ich mache mich da nicht zum
anwalt von leuten die ich überhaupt kein
bisschen leiden nach ich versteh ich
versuche nur meine eigene moral
einzubringen die motive und die
denkweisen und die sichtweisen der
menschen von damals zu verstehen
und da weil sie alle nicht mehr erzielen
können nicht nur dass heute 100 jahre
später möglich sein
ich sehe zum beispiel das höchst kluge
leute das geht nicht nur hin im busch
auch der meinung sind dass gilt vertritt
das durch für warten
das gilt für max weber das gilt für
tausende
heute einen guten ruf arm dass da irgend
etwas nicht richtig gelaufen ist und was
ist das gewesen
du hast gerade gesagt wird wir haben
tatsächlich damals eine noch nicht ganz
entschieden dazu das klima so paradigma
stimmt diese 15 minuten wir wissen alle
dass wussten auch die von damals schon
dass die deutschen maximal noch bis zum
frühjahr durchhalten konnten früher 19
mal in soja 90 die entscheidende frage
für die menschen damals ist hätten wir
nicht die waffen geschmissen hätten wir
vielleicht einen besseren frieden
gekriegt aber da ich an alle argumente
die brücken haben sehr genau beobachtet
dass ein flotten ob er eine flotte
operation zu einer fernbeziehung von
london führen könnte es gibt sehr klare
hinweise darauf dass die
friedensbedingungen sich nicht
verbessert sondern verschlechtert hätten
also das ist ein lesen der quellen gegen
den strich die mir an der stelle einfach
zu weit geht weil sie sozusagen eine
position einnimmt die finde ich wirklich
internationale forschungsergebnisse wie
sozusagen nicht reflektiert es gibt
einen anderen punkt der mir ganz wichtig
ist du kennst aus meiner sicht viel zu
stark zwischen dem militärischen und der
heimatfront
das entscheidende ist aber das wissen
wir doch seit vielen jahren das an der
militärischen front wir keine auflösung
haben aber eine form der selbst
demobilisierung die in dem augenblick
beginnt als die soldaten den glauben an
den sieg verloren haben und das was du
nahelegt mit einer interpretation ist
und das finde ich gefährlich es ist dann
deutlich in der geschichte das sage ich
jetzt dann doch mal ein bisschen
kommentiert es ist gefährlich zu sagen
dass die revolution und das was in
deutschland innenpolitisch passiert
vielleicht doch ein bisschen dran schuld
war dafür dass deutschland den krieg
verloren hat diese mit einem schlage ich
nehme diese mappus an diesem argument
leistest du versucht werden das nicht
mein agent moment wenn du zwischen
legende und lüge hier einen solchen ich
finde einen etwas office tischen
unterschied ist dass nur historical
correctness oder ist es mehr
das ist im kern eine frage der
plausibilität von argumenten und es ist
eine frage der internationalen
forschungen wir wissen heute dass
deutschland den krieg militärisch im
sommer 1918 im spätsommer frühjahr 1918
verloren zwischendurch bevor herr krömer
ich antworten landsfrau fehlemann was
sagen sie zu diesem historic diesem
history also ich gebe ihnen recht also
ich würde auch sagen dass es deutlich
war dass deutschland den krieg verloren
hatte aber die frage ist ob nicht dieses
durchhalten bis zum schluss also dieses
kämpfen bis zum letzten ob es nicht
darum ging dass die bestimmte kreise
meinten dass dieses dieses durchkämpfen
dass das ehrenvoller gewesen wäre als
dieser waffenstillstand diese form von
der kapitulation kann man ja nicht sagen
aber diese form von verhandlung gewesen
wäre und dass das vielleicht auch ein
bisschen dieser kern des des vorwurfs
war und was natürlich ganz klar was der
wahre kern oder was ein wahrer kern der
durchschuss legende ist ist natürlich in
gewisser weise die die heimat die nicht
durchhält wenn man das in dieser
perspektive sagen will die leute hatten
als kaiser wilhelm september 19 zu den
krupp werken kram und durchhalte rede
hielt schrien die leute ja hunger wir
wollen endlich frieden war das nur die
stimmung der arbeiterschaft die stimmung
des bürgertums eine andere oder war das
identisch also in deutschland war die
gesamtstimmung wir haben den krieg satt
wir haben nichts zu essen und um was
kämpfen will in das ist kann man so
einfach nicht unterscheiden zwischen
arbeitern und bürgerlichen wenn man
sieht ist es eigentlich noch erstaunlich
wie gut die neunte kriegsanleihen im
september 18 gezeichnet wird aber sie
ist deutlich schlechter gezeichnet als
etwa die achter kriegs anlage vom märz
und nicht mal als die hälfte davon und
gehört zu den am schlechtesten
gezeichneten kriegsanleihen aber das
überhaupt noch jemand hin läuft und die
kriegs anleihe im september zeichnet ist
eigentlich für mich im nachhinein schon
noch wunder denn ich weiß auch dass es
damals kompanien gab die maximal noch 50
leute hatten und dass das bild von otto
dix fünf man die da ganz oben stehen
kompanie zum rapport angetreten nur ganz
ein wenig ironisch ist gegenüber der
realität und ich weiß auch wie die
internationale forschung und die dumme
ist aber zu der ich auch irgendwie
gehöre dass ich weiß auch dass die
deutschen maximal noch bis zum frühjahr
hätten durchhalten können und das mit
der viertelstunde vom klimaschutz
vielleicht auch schon wieder zu
trainieren und besserer friedlich drin
gewesen wäre ein besserer frieden drin
gewesen im frühjahr 19 was meinen sie
oder wäre er noch schlimmer gewesen
hätten die deutschen was früher was hier
geschehe man sie gerade angesprochen hat
dilemmas wie sie nicht nur raten noch
vorschlägt anfang november ende oktober
wie es aus allen möglichen münder kommt
in dem fall auch wieder mal zwei selbe
zu ziemlich ja wir müssen noch mal
wieder an der heimat grenze eine eine
mauer aufrichten und dann sollen die
anderen doch mal gucken ob so
rüberkommen aber die reaktion
das sind sind doch katastrophal es ist
am schluss wilhelm groener der
nachfolger von ludendorff der als es
wirklich darauf ankommt nämlich nach der
unterzeichnung des oder vor der
unterzeichnung des versailler vertrages
sagt dafür gibt es überhaupt keine
chance und selbst ernst reusch sagt zu
dem berühmten aufsatz von von rathenau
in der vossischen zeitung das sind dinge
die sozusagen keine chance auf
realisierung haben übrigens weil die
menschen wissen was drohen könnte
nämlich eine besetzung deutschlands ein
einmarsch der alliierten truppen mit
allen konsequenzen und eine völlige
enthemmung der gewalt das ist eine art
von konjunktiv geschichte die ich muss
ich noch mal sagen an der stelle
wirklich ganz deutlich die französischen
soldaten mit gegangen werden an dem
punkt also sicher gesagt dass ich das
nicht sicher ist dass der
generalstabschef der amerikaner und das
autogramm ja immer mehr nach europa die
mit europa kommen dass die sich sehr
genau überlegen was bedeutet es wenn wir
nach deutschland einmarschieren was für
eine in themen von gewalt kann das
bedeuten und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
es unter solchen umständen mit weiteren
hohen verlusten der alliierten truppen
leichtere friedensbedingungen gegeben
hat die wir mir nicht einleuchten und
bei allen die ich mir angeguckt habe die
auf diesen raten artikel reagieren ist
der tenor eigentlich vor allem kritisch
die sagen das ist eine einzelmeinung
aber das ist kein genereller trend aber
vorarbeit leben ein aufruf der spd zb
vom 15 oktober der genau dasselbe sagt
der spd diese idee die raten nur dann
etwas exzentrisch äußert ich ja in sehr
vielen köpfen mit oktober 15 18 oktober
kommt ein großer aufruft der spd gegner
gegenargument es gibt vor der abdankung
wilhelms gibt es eine szene in spa im
hauptquartier der deutschen wo den
kommandeuren fragen vorgelegt werden wie
man die situation einschätzt das ist
repräsentativ weil da alle wichtigen
front kommandeure gefragt werden und das
widerlegt eindeutig was du gesagt hast
die kommandeure sehen keine möglichkeit
diesen kampf fortzusetzen weder auf
französischem und belgischem boden noch
auf deutschem und in dem augenblick
der entscheidende augenblick die
abdankung von wilhelm im grunde genommen
eingeleitet also wir müssen ein bisschen
unterscheiden zwischen dem was wir
historisch versuchs klar wissen und dem
was für die damaligen menschen
zugänglich war
aber du vermisst uns ich bin jetzt 100
jahre später der auffassung dass unser
wissen um die objektiven situation
damals vielleicht eine spur auseinander
gilt mit dem handlos motivationen und
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten der menschen
von damals wie sieht es denn aus man ist
überzeugt dass dann hinterher im feld
unverzüglich die seitenbesucher seid
alle unbesiegter was sollen die leute
denn glauben und gesicht sein und dann
so diese verrückten konditionen bekommen
und an diesem massaker schuld sein
und an so vielen millionen schuld sein
wer will das denn aushalten da ist das
problem
und wenn ich jetzt hier gerücht werde
dass ich irgendwelche deutschland
wiederhole und die geschichte da nicht
kenne
doch stehen die ziemlich genau ich
unterscheide nur zwischen dem was wir
heute wissen und dem was die damals
wissen konnten ich weiß auch dass
aufgrund von daten aus an aufruf und
anderen aufrufen derselben art überhaupt
in münchen erst die situation zu
explosiv geworden ist weil nämlich die
soldaten in die kasernen in münchen
bisschen die nase voll hatten und dann
zum eisner auf die lust wiese gelaufen
sind sagt vater seit gerd das
grundproblem ist wenn du die
zeitgenössischen einschätzungen nimmst
und fragst dich ob an der
dolchstoßlegende nicht doch etwas dran
gewesen ist
das ist das ist das problem das wir
unterscheiden müssen zwischen dem
nachträglichen wissen der historiker und
der subjektiven wahrnehmung der
zeitgenossen da bin ich bei dir aber das
eigene zu nehmen um dann zu fragen war
an der sogenannten dolchstoßlegende was
dran das ist dass wir gegen ich mich
jetzt verlassen wir mal die
dolchstoßlegende oder auch nicht sie
bezog sich auf das was im november 18
geschah die deutsche revolution da setzt
ja eine wi lenin große hoffnungen auf
sie und wurde enttäuscht da gibt es ja
das schöne zitat wenn die deutschen auf
dem bahnhof eine revolution machen
wollen kaufen sie sich vorher ein
bahnsteigkarte ist das nur eine
mentalitätsfrage frau fehler macht oder
warum ist diese deutsche blogs
gescheitert ja ist sie gescheitert ich
weiß nicht also im letztlich ist ja die
das was nachher raus kam bei der
revolution ist ja in teilen auch das was
die mehrheit der bevölkerung gewünscht
hat also die revolutionäre die räte die
arbeiterräte soldaten wollten ja was
anderes aber aber damit konnten sie sich
eben in dieser ich sag mal in einer
radikalen form nicht durchsetzen
das viel versäumt worden ist von der von
seiten der regierung bestimmte maßnahmen
umzusetzen die sozialisierung von
betrieben demokratisierung des militärs
und so weit darüber kann man sicherlich
streiten aber am ende ist ja mit der
wahl zur nationalversammlung das war das
zentrale ziel zum beispiel von von ebert
dass er das schützt dass er diese dass
diese wahlen zur nationalversammlung
auch stattfinden und das ist ja dann
auch tatsächlich hat dann stattgefunden
hat eben auch gezeigt dass die mehrheit
der bevölkerung nicht unbedingt auf
seiten der ganz radikalen linken stand
also insofern weiß ich jetzt nicht ob
man in jedem fall von der gescheiterten
revolution ist die frage wie man
revolution definiert wer macht den
besten revolution ist das also ich habe
so ein bisschen der schacht bord die
revolution der soldaten die garnison
soldaten nicht nur in kiewit hafen und
so weiter zwar sind diese daten die
aufstehen die nicht mehr wollen sie auch
nicht mehr an die wand gebracht werden
wollen für die sinnlose abschlachten und
die satten plus und das ist der
wirkliche kern da werden dann das
verbindet sich dann hinter mitarbeiter
retten aber die soldaten und ihre welt
sind der anfang
und dann geht es für die spd also für
ebert und scheidemann und wie sie heißen
im grunde nur noch darum diesen aufstand
zu verwalten kanalisieren und ja das ist
ja das schon das war schon im januar
1918 das problem dass er sich an die
spitze der streikenden bei munitions
steigt im januar 18 stellt was ihm
hinterher also wirklich schrecklich
vorgeworfen worden
in der weimarer republik von der rechten
dann sagt ihr habt ja recht ich verstehe
euch ihr habt ja recht uns jetzt geht
man wieder an eure arbeit dieses
bedürfnis der spd also beruhigend zu
wirken dabei zu sein die in den griff zu
bekommen das haben wir 19
exakt dieselbe situation man muss sich
noske geht nach kiel da macht das nicht
ungeschickt um die leute zu beruhigen er
schafft es auch um ruhe und ordnung
schaffen das schlagwort der spd zu
diesem zeitpunkt ich ruhe und ordnung
schaffen war da so gesehen
wer nur hin wenn ich vorhin mit garten
eigentlich nicht überein gestimmt hat an
der stelle bin ich bei es ist schön die
revolution der ruhe und ordnung jetzt
ist eine revolution die ja eine partei
die mehrheit sozialdemokratie in die
verantwortung bringt in einer besonders
schwierigen situation in der krieg ist
verloren man muss waffenstillstand
bedingungen akzeptieren man muss
millionen von soldaten zurückführen
und in dieser situation hat keiner von
denen dem sinn eine deutsche
oktoberrevolution zu wagen und das
entspricht aber überhaupt nicht dem
kalkül wenn man so will der staatsraison
der sozialdemokraten ja zeigen wollen
dass sie keine vaterlandslose gesellen
sind sie operieren ja im grunde genommen
immer mal schon diesem trauma von von
bismarcks anti sozialismus gesetzgebung
sie setzen in gewisser weise noch mal
das fort was die fraktion der spd 1914
gemacht hat aber diese revolution
produziert ein schwieriges erbe weil sie
mit der spaltung der deutschen linken
endet denn einem teil der linken und es
sind nicht nur die sportler kisten um
lenin um liebknecht und luxemburg
sondern auch schon noch mehr arbeiter
die sich mehr gewünscht haben als das
was die spd macht und dabei geht es
jetzt nicht um eine deutsche variante
der oktoberrevolution es geht etwa um
die frage wie viel kontinuität in der
bürokratie die armee als staat im staate
und aus dieser art der revolution
entsteht im grunde genommen eine schwere
belastung für die weimarer republik
nämlich eine gespaltene linke die diese
spaltung im grunde genommen bis an ihr
ende nicht wirklich über geräte dürfen
das ist glaube ich ein ganz ganz
entscheidender punkt der ja wenn wir uns
das bis heute angucken die prozession zu
den gräbern von knecht und luxemburg bis
in die gegenwart dass das wollte ich
gerade sagen dass hier ein gutes
stichwort pakistan waren
eine ziemlich kleine gruppe die leute
die die revolution machen und was mich
jetzt keine rolle
zur trauer zu für rosa luxemburg und
lieblich sind hunderttausende kommen und
das macht das aus die leute hatten ein
klares verständnis dafür sie hatten eine
sympathie für deren bemühungen den krieg
zu beenden eine gerechte gesellschaft zu
schaffen und so weiter aber entspannt
ich hab keinen sparta kisten
die spd kommt in den geruch sie kommt in
den verdacht sich mit den falschen zu
verbünden mit dem state grüne würde man
daraus entsteht im grunde genommen und
das finde ich immer wenn man sich die
situation anschaut wie wie hätte die
regierung anders handeln können ich
meine es war
gewalttätige ausschreitungen macht uns
hat das jetzt gezeigt aber wo war der
der weg wo man hätte anders als in ja
immer auch wie ein damoklesschwert die
frage über alldem wie reagieren die
sieger wie reagieren die alliierten
denke ich und das ist ein ganz
entscheidender punkt den gerd krumeich
auch angesprochen hat aber auf denen wir
sicher auch noch einmal zu sprechen
kommen sollten das ist die große angst
davor dass ein destabilisierte
deutschland zur plattform für einen
einfall der bolschewiki wird übrigens
ist dass das argument mit dem man in
paris bei der friedensverhandlungen bis
zum schluss versucht gute bedingungen zu
bekommen indem man sagt ihr müsst ein
interesse daran haben dass dieses
deutschland stabil ist denn wenn es
instabil ist wenn du überall
räterepublik von bremen ist wird das
ein riesiges propos friedenskonferenz in
das seil in deutschland hatten wir ja
die nationalversammlung die versuchte
januar 90 eine tolle neue verfassung zu
formulieren und dann kamen die nachricht
im sommer über die bedingungen der
sieger und der ministerpräsident des
reiches philipp scheidemann rief aus
welcher hand müsste nicht verdorren die
sich und uns in diese fesseln legt hat
war sei die ganze schöne demokratische
entwicklung weimars verdorben
das kann die glaube ich keiner sagen
aber es war schon eine belastung
dieser sogenannte schuld paragraf da
können wir uns die haare heute noch
ausreifen und auch schrecklich drüber
streiten über den schuld paragrafen dass
deutschland die alleinschuld am ersten
weltkrieg
das ist das problem die deutschland muss
bezahlen so lautet der 231 weil für alle
schäden die die alliierten und ihre
verbündeten erlitten haben
durch die aggression deutschlands im
deutschen text im offiziellen deutschen
text wird aggression übrigens nur mit
angriffs- übersetzt und die deutschen
sagen das klingt heute schon fast
verrückt die deutsche regierung wir
wollen bezahlen wir haben ja verloren
aber wenn mal nur bezahlen was wir
selber kaputt gemacht habe
wir wollen nicht dafür bezahlen dass die
alliierten ihre eigenen kathedralen
kaputt geschossen haben also diese art
von deutsche rechen heftigkeit wir
wollen bezahlen was wir in belgien
gemacht haben und beim einfach in
nordfrankreich aber dann ist schluss die
gegend von 20 milliarden die sie auch
gerne bezahlen würden
aber das sind dann diese fantasie zahlen
mit über 200 milliarden die da auch
schon im raum schulen die keiner gemerkt
kurz und gut die deutsche nach
überzeugung der alliierten und da steht
in den text nicht nur in der mantel note
vom klima so da steht auch im text die
aggression der deutschen ist der grund
weshalb sie bezahlen müssen und die
deutschen sagen ja das ist ja nur der
angriff gewesen und übersetzen das auch
so und glauben es zum teil bis heute
jung
bis heute steht in unseren offiziellen
quellen sammlungen immer noch an
un-sprecher französischen regierung und
der französischen und englischen fassung
steht aggression und adressen
ich habe jetzt noch mal gerade ein
amerikaner gefragt weil das schild auch
angriff heißen kann auf englischen heißt
nur angriffe ist aus einer ganz
aggressive grundhaltung ein angriff ist
dagegen haben sich die deutschen
bewerten als das kann man diskutieren
aber die wussten noch nicht so genau wie
wir dass wir wirklich alleine am krieg
schuld war die folge dieser
unverstandener lagen das ist was wir
eben auch hatte 1918 das dass die
deutschen nicht verstanden haben wieso
diese niederlage kam und wieso sind sie
dann plötzlich so schnell kam und dann
eben dieser dann wäre das gegangen ohne
diesen vorwurf danke
dann hätte man unter umständen ganz
anders abrechnung und sich einige jetzt
versammelt sich alles um die schuldfrage
die der brokdorf ganze macht das zur
kernfrage aber es ist auch falsch zu
sagen dass brokdorf das erfunden hat die
anderen sind auch der meinung dass die
kernfrage ist allerdings in der regel
die zitiert haben von scheidemann mit
der verdorrten hand ist nicht einmal
gibt bord von der kriegsschuldfrage nur
von den reparationen die man
ungerechterweise überall in der welt und
die und die deutschen gebietsverluste
und solchen kriegsschuldfrage lassen sie
mich eine frage weil das war sehr
wichtig weil er gesagt hatte die wussten
damals nicht so genau wie wir heute dass
deutschland aber meine wir hatten ja die
diskussionsreihe christoph verklagt ja
sagt christopher klagt dass die
übeltäter für den ausbruch dieses
krieges nicht nur in berlin in wien und
belgrad sondern auch in paris und in
sankt petersburg gesessen seien also
insofern wissen die historiker doch
wollte mehr als die menschen damals ja
das glaube ich schon ein bisschen
komplizierter wir dürfen nicht vergessen
als die bolschewiki zur macht kommen
beginnen sie damit die archive zu öffnen
und das beginnt eigentlich 1917
allerspätestens ein wettlauf um die
dauer maria hat die deutungsmacht über
die dokumente und das betrifft viele
fragen und
dann beginnen im grunde genommen
debatten die sich würde ich sagen bis
zur debatte von 2014 in irgendeiner form
fortgesetzt haben der kern dessen was in
paris in versailles passiert ist dass
die alliierten vor allen dingen
frankreich den krieg zu einem verbrechen
macht da darin liegt auch die neue
qualität dieses friedensvertrages dass
er nicht mehr von der prinzipiellen
gleichrangigkeit der staatlichen akteure
ausgeht sondern im grunde genommen die
politik moralisiert da deshalb würde
sich das heer wird dieser schuldkomplex
plötzlich zu einer eigenen dynamischen
aktivität einer einem medialen ereignis
das alle anderen aspekte dieses
vertrages in den hintergrund rückt oder
man bezieht alles die ausgelieferten
eisenbahnwaggons die abzutreten gebiete
nur auf diesen komplex der schuld und es
ist eben der schuldkomplex und nicht der
komplex der verantwortung und darin
liegt diese neue qualität und das
erklärt eben auch diese enorme empörung
der deutschen es kommt noch etwas
weiteres hinzu der waffenstillstand wird
abgeschlossen im in der berufung auf
mindestens 14 punkte die idee eines
rechtsfriedens und von dem fühlt man
sich im grunde genommen betrogen wie
wilson wird dann der große verräter und
mit ihm wenn man so will das modell der
westlichen republik für viele deutsche
weil sie nicht das bekommen haben was
sie sich im november 1918 und im juni
1919 erhofft haben
ich wollte wissen der hat ja gesagt ich
zitiere favre german als singer schütten
sei nicht als deutscher hätte ich diesen
vertrag nicht unterschrieben hätten sie
den vertrag unterschrieben hat ruhig als
andere der politiker mag wie bei denen
acht hat ich hätte ihn nicht
unterschrieben das ist ungefähr 15 jahre
her in eine antrittsvorlesung habe ich
an kirchlichen brief von einem sehr
renommierten kollegen dessen namen ich
jetzt hier nicht sagen sagte er komme
ich das ist ja wissenschaftlich
interessant was sie sagen
sehr interessant aber es ist doch extrem
gefährlich ich habe den kollegen dann
geantwortet dass ich mich da sehr
bedanken und das ich eben wieder
bestätigt
dass unsere wissenschaft manchmal sehr
gefährlich ist da aber es gibt ich hätte
ich nichts unterschrieben ich glaube er
sagt einen unterschied zwischen sehr
guten fragen und fragen die man nicht
beantworten muss ich finde über diese
frage nachzudenken ist sehr gut aber ich
würde sie nie beantworten weil darin
findet sich auch ein stück weit ein
fasten hybris urteil steckt als wenn man
von heute beurteilen könnte wie die
handlungs bedingungen der deutschen
reichsregierung waren die damit rechnen
mussten einmarsch der alliierten
zerteilung der reichs einheit wir haben
separatismus bewegungen das diskutiere
ich alles gerne aber nicht mit dem
ergebnis ich hätte unterschrieben oder
nicht unterschrieb werde das reicht dann
wirklich besetzt worden wäre es zerteilt
wo auf dem schläger gehabt sonst der der
ober also der der chef der der
alliierten general stäbe und heck haben
darauf bezieht sich grüner dann im
sommer 1919 haben ausgearbeitete pläne
für einen vormarsch der truppen bis zur
weser es sind diese pläne die dann
grüner als nachfolger von ludendorff bei
der entscheidenden frage wie schätzt das
militär die situation ein dazu bringen
zu sagen abschließen
wir haben gleichzeitig die situation
dass die franzosen alles tun die in die
franzosen tun alles um im grunde
genommen eine art von raimondi sierung
des reiches also eine zerteilung mit
separaten friedensverträgen zu erreichen
diese gefahr ist sehr akut der junge
adenauer erlebe das sehr bewusst keine
pläne für eine westdeutsche rheinische
republik diese gefahr ist glaube ich im
frühjahr akut und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen gleichzeitig eine räterepublik
in münchen
gleichzeitig eine räterepublik in ungarn
eine über eine hochkomplizierte
gesamteuropäische situation ja in der
sind jetzt vier monate und tischen das
ist noch keine retter die räterepublik
in münchen wird ja ja ja bei diesem
problem in münchen aber eben paris redet
man nicht über münchen sondern über
ungarn da muss man auch noch mal ein
bisschen über deutschland hinaus gucken
also die deutschen hätten praktisch
keine reale chance gehabt diesen vertrag
abzulesen die bei uns bereich besetzt
worden
es gibt etwas das ist doch dass ich doch
das reich besitzen wir wollen mal sehen
ob ihre soldaten mit gehen und bis heute
kann das geld aus die arbeit von grüner
kaban der dann wirklich für die
französischen soldaten der größte
spezialist ist da durchaus ambivalent
aus dem was die an was du da hast an
brieflichen äußerungen irgendwie wollen
system bosch von noch zeigen aber dass
sie schon aber nochmal weiter kämpfen
ich weiß nicht was passiert wäre mit dem
der hoffnung der deutschen linken dass
die internationale solidarität spricht
wenn eine solche situation der besetzung
damals passiert wäre das ist nicht
vergleichbar mit der ur besetzung mit
der hirn und diese doch auch nur als
provisorisch angesehene rheinland
besetzt und nein das wäre eine andere
situation gewesen derzeit der effektiven
zerschlagung deutschlands und ob dafür
die französischen soldaten noch nicht
gibt das nur als problem gewesen
trotzdem nicht unterschrieben ich weiß
doch die hand verdorrt ende 1918 stehen
über zwei millionen amerikanischen
soldaten in europa übrigens gibt es noch
ein anderes argument dass mir viel zu
kurz gekommen ist also wir reden von
seinen den großen akteuren alles wichtig
viel interessanter ist was im sommer
1919 eine ebene darunter passiert
nämlich bei den wirtschaftsexperten das
sind zum teil leute die uns dann nach 45
wieder begegnen werden leute die für die
europäische integration sehr wichtig
werden schub an monet und auf der
deutschen seite leute wie zum beispiel
der bankier warburg oder karl melchior
und die unterhalten sich im grunde
genommen darüber wie kann man aus dieser
verfahrenen situation rauskommen und sie
denken daran bestimmte
schlüsselindustrien wie zum beispiel
montanindustrie in deutschland zu
internationalisieren zu europäisieren
das was wir dann nach nur 45 irgendwann
erleben werden weil sie verstanden haben
wie stark die wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeit zwischen den europäischen
ländern
längst geworden ist das heißt es gibt in
diesem augenblick der maximalen
emotionalen konfrontation ein denken
über den tag hinaus und das finde ich
viel spannender
übrigens die deutschen auf der ebene
sagen ja natürlich müsst ihr
unterschreiben weil wir nur dann das
wirtschaftliche potenzial deutschlands
wieder zur geltung bringen können und
das gibt uns die möglichkeit sozusagen
langfristig auch die härten dieses
vertrags wieder abzuschleifen wunderbare
nette ideen in die zukunft reichen aber
sie kam ja nicht zur geltung sie wurden
ja nicht angenommen und waren ja auch in
der bevölkerung nicht präsent wie war es
denn eigentlich bei den frauen in
deutschland die kriegten zwar das
wahlrecht der wunderbar ganz toll hatten
sie auch verdient nach diesem break aber
war die erbitterung die bei den männern
herrscht
das ging ja auch an den stolz war das
bei den frauen auch der fall oder hatten
die in deutschland vor allem mit den
nöten und den zwängen des alltags zu tun
das war ja nach wie vor noch hungersnot
und die spanische grippe war ja auch
noch immer genau also dass das ist
wirklich auch nicht zu unterschätzen
also erstmal das frauenwahlrecht war ja
kein sozusagen kein belohnung für die
beteiligung am krieg oder die dass das
durchhalten im krieg also das war
wirklich eine maßnahme der revolution
oder ein geschenk der revolution wenn
man so will beziehungsweise war eben
auch schon von von deutschen
frauenverbänden natürlich schon sehr
lange vorbereitet worden
ganz im gegenteil ich sehe es eher als
problematisch dass das frauenwahlrecht
in diesem moment der militärischen
niederlage kam und das haben auch viele
hält sich die frauen damals gesehen also
wenn man das vergleicht das männer
wahlrecht oder das allgemeine gleiche
wahlrecht zum reichstag 18 71 was schon
quasi da war das war quasi in einem sieg
geboren also in einem militärischen von
einem militärischen sieg
angeschoben worden und das ist im grunde
auch ein bisschen das problem des
frauenwahlrechts warum auch irgendwie
denke ich so ein bisschen die
geschlechterordnung in der weimarer
republik auch serien unter anderem sehr
in unordnung geraten ist und das ist das
eine also diese belastung die eben auch
an in dieser demokratischen
partizipation der sichtbar wurde
was immer auch im diese diskussion um
die frauen im krieg um ihr durchhalten
um ihre hitler hat nachher diese jammer
wäre genau also in jammer briefe immer
in anführungszeichen natürlich und ganz
interessant ist dass zum beispiel
konservative frauenverbände durchaus
nach oder rechts völkische
frauenverbände durchaus nach 1919 eben
gesagt haben oder in den ersten jahren
der weimarer republik sie wenn frauen an
der macht gewesen wäre wären wäre dieser
vertrag nicht unterzeichnet und die
frauen als legende gab es ja der pariser
friedenskonferenz wird es eine
internationale konferenz der frauen-liga
die eine der interessantesten und
schärfsten kritiker des versailler
vertrages formuliert sehen sie mal wenn
die frauen wenn man auf die frauen
gehörte tun sagte ja frankreichs maßstab
forscht der eben schon mal erwähnt wurde
in der st sinngemäß das ist kein frieden
das ist ein waffenstillstand auf 20
jahren hat er ja bis aus ja genau recht
behalten gibt es sozusagen doch in
gewissem sinne eine gerade linie die vom
ersten bis zum zweiten weltkrieg führt
hat mich die schwierigste frage gelegt
und nicht ja schon sehnsüchtig die
geschichte schon als sehr viel offener
an und wir haben auch eine phase gehabt
in der wärmeren 20 bis 29 jährigen sagen
kann das hätte sich auch noch ganz
anders
entwickeln können aber es hat über die
ganze zeit ein kriegstrauma gegeben
das sage ich mache so umgestellt und das
hatte auch ich auch in der guten zeit
von weimar nicht überwunden worden dass
gegen nicht und als es das ökonomisch
spieler schlechter geht 28 29 das sind
genau die zehn jahre die individuelle
traumata brauchen sich so zu lösen
29 30 in der wirtschaftskrise kommt
plötzlich nicht von ungefähr
der weltkrieg wieder mit einer
ungeheuren macht in die literatur ins
kulturelle leben in die erinnerung die
kollektive erinnerung nicht nur in
deutschland kommt ist immer das
stichwort dafür aber das ist nur die
spitze einer riesigen bewegung der neuen
bewältigung und des verstehens des
weltkrieges als eine als eine
katastrophe und als eine unter umständen
der spielrechte eine hoffnung
also ich halt gemacht ist dann schon
noch dieses bild was frosch gebraucht
die das gibt ja auch viele andere die
damals sagen dass nach 20 jahren
er macht hier gerade die geburt eines
neuen kriegs szenarios schon in 20
jahren ist es soweit das ist ein relativ
guter topos damals 19
aber natürlich war das nicht
unvermeidbar da musste auch nicht an die
macht kommen aber es hat seine gründe um
die liegen auch die hennen mit wasser
und mieter nicht verstanden und nicht
verdauten niederlage zusammen dass ihm
applaudiert worden ist ich sage es mal
ganz kurz dem hitler ist nicht so
applaudiert worden wegen seines kruden
antisemitismus das hat man gesagt das
treiben bei dem ausländer an gemacht ist
und die ganzen rabauke rhein treiben mit
dem aus das haben sie sich vertan die
rantzau kiefer an dem satz von
forschungs ja noch was anderes
interessant nämlich dass man ihn auch so
interpretieren kann jede generation muss
ich den frieden neuer arbeiten
solche aus solche solche äußerungen gibt
es zum beispiel auch von bismarck und
anderen staatsmännern ich glaube dass
forsch das relativ realistisch gesehen
hat aber klar ist der versailler vertrag
ist nicht ein perpetuiert baarer
friedens zustand sondern er ist eine
basis mit dem dann die akteure der
zwanziger und dreißiger jahre umgehen
mussten und viele staatsmänner des 20
jahre des 19 jahrhunderts wussten dass
das auch ein flexibler korridor ist die
hoffnung der menschen nach diesen vier
jahren oder fast fünf jahren krieg war
das nach einem total easy retten krieg
ein totaler frieden kommen sollte und
dass das hat nicht funktioniert aber zu
glauben dass mit wer sei sozusagen 19 39
41 45 determiniert ist das würde im
grunde genommen ja den großen hoffnungen
die es 1918 19 eben auch gegeben hat
noch einmal die grundlage entziehen es
gab schon so etwas wie einen offenen
moment der war belastet keine frage der
hypotheken aber der verpflichtete die
kommende generation auch auf eine
bestimmte form der politik und die
musste man sozusagen aktiv neu gestalten
darin steckte aber auch
handlungsfreiheit
gleichwohl sagte aber frau fehler man
ein jahr völlig unverdächtiger zeitzeuge
wie theodor heuss der spätere
bundespräsident der ausgangspunkt der
nationalsozialistischen bewegung ist
nicht münchen sondern wahr sei
da klingt ja fast doch der zwangsläufige
weg in den zweiten weltkrieg
japan muss es so sagen 1918 führt nicht
direkt zu hitler aber hitler wäre
undenkbar ohne 1918
so muss man es glauben so kommen würde
auch seine notwendigkeit hat es da in
keiner weise gegeben aber viel ist an
der faszination des nationalsozialismus
erklärt sich genau aus dieser nicht
überwundenen kriegskunst ration hitler
sagt ich mache euch wieder groß ich mach
uns wieder groß die schuld wird geteilt
das unrecht wird gedig da kriegt er die
strahlen
schon ab 29 30 ich hab es übrigens
einzigen zu sein im juni 1940 als er im
eisenbahnwaggon von compean das ist im
grunde genommen für die dort für viele
deutsche noch einmal den ersten welt
gewinnt gewinnt und es gibt die sd
berichte aus dem sommer 1940 die belegen
zu keinem zeitpunkt war die zustimmung
so groß und das verhängnis ist dass er
mit diesem ansehens kapital sozusagen
ein jahr später den krieg gegen die
sowjetunion starten
das kapital natürlich auch deswegen weil
viele deutsche die illusion hatten jetzt
käme ein sieg frieden mit england oder
sie hätten ihre ruhe können wir uns auf
den satz einigen zum aufstieg hitlers
hat es nicht kommen müssen es hätte auch
völlig anders kommen können
absolut die geschichte kommt nie so wie
sie hat scheinbar kommen müssen der
schlimmste satz den ich allen
studierenden immer auszutreiben versuche
ist der satz ist kam wie es kommen
musste das ist in der geschichte der
fall
hitler hat systematisch aufgebaut auf
dem kaum halt nicht bewältigt niederlage
und das ist entscheidend ob er jetzt an
ihm schuld ist eine ganz andere frage
aber der kern der erfolgsgeschichte des
ns ist erstmal die überwindung über ist
ganz interessant ich hab einen satz
gelesen letztes von hitler 28 in einer
großen rede burscheid hätte die republik
sich 1918 nicht ergeben sondern diesen
ball von dem wir eben gesprochen haben
diese levanas gemacht dann hätten wir
auch zur republik gestanden
also das ist zwar sehr isolierter satz
aber er muss das sagen damals 28 noch um
bestimmte leute zu interessieren
also dass hier müsste man mal nachgehen
der letzte aufzeichnung im bunker kurz
vor dem selbstmord lautet sinngemäß wird
kein zweiter november 1918 in der
deutschen geschichte geben das ist schon
ein fixpunkt seine schnelligkeit
lichtpunkte eingestellt
nun gibt es ja das schöne wort vom
dreißigjährigen krieg des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts der von 1914 bis 45 reichte
so gesehen wäre ja dann 1918 19 gar
nicht mal der aufbruch in eine
trügerische kurze zeit eines brüchigen
frieden sondern nur ein teil dieses 30
jährigen dagegen noch in ganz alaska
nicht stoppen
dann spreche ich plötzlich von
hundertjährigen krieg
wir haben leute kriegen wir haben auch
heute noch kriege die in gewisser weise
noch eine erbschaft des ersten
weltkriegs sind sein die nach ihren
gucken die dortigen vertreibungen dann
hat er einen wunderbaren auf satz
zugeschrieben aus seinem buch noch in
der zeit eine zeit da kann man schon
noch
also ich finde dieses 30 jährige krieg
das ist eine art diskutierten topos nein
das war kann das team schon deshalb
nicht weil er ja praktisch allen
akteuren der zwanziger und dreißiger
jahre im nachhinein noch die freiheit
nimmt es besser zu machen
es gibt von reinhart koselleck dem
großen historiker das wort von der
vergangenen zukunft und wir dürfen den
zeitgenossen von 1918 19 nicht diese
vergangene zukunft
wir müssen auf die hypotheken auf die
belastungen gucken aber wenn wir das
andere geschäft betreiben dann machen
wir eigentlich nur noch die rezession
ist ische geschichte und dann erklären
wir alles was sozusagen das war 33 39 41
45 schiefgegangen ist aus einem
geburtsfehler von 1914 das ist sehr
suggestiv aber es hat glaube ich mit
nützlichen der geschichtswissenschaft
wenig zu tun
man steht ja 1918 19 für enttäuschte
illusion als auch für chancen und für
eine neue weltordnung war das denn nun
der anfang des amerikanischen
jahrhunderts 1918 frau fehler man dass
er möglicherweise in diesen jahren 100
jahre später nicht gerade strahlende
höhepunkte erreicht sondern vielleicht
sogar dem ende sich zone
ja also sicherlich das kann man sagen
der aufstieg amerikas zu groß macht hat
sicherlich da begonnen
das hat ja viele fraktionen noch gegeben
das war ja kein
der aufstieg das kann man sagen aber es
war 1918 waren dramatisches jahr für für
viele länder also man kann die glaube
ich stück für stück durchgehend sie
haben das ja auch in ihrem buch gemacht
und man sieht eigentlich dass es dass
kein land irgendwie und beschädigt da
raus gegangen ist na also
insofern ist das jahr 1918 sicherlich
für die internationale politik für die
internationale lage ganz entscheiden
können aber trotzdem war es ja so dass
sich die amerikaner zurückgezogen haben
nach besser sie haben ja die europäer
sich selbst überlassen die nicht mehr
dem völkerbund beigetreten was wäre denn
gewesen oder hätte es eine chance
gegeben dass amerika seine interessen
seine punkte
die 14 punkte wilsons dass die die ganze
sache positive hätten ausgehen lassen
und vielleicht sogar der weimarer
republik eine größere chance gegeben
hätten
es ist ja nicht so dass die usa sich
komplett zurückziehen sie ziehen sich
politisch zurück aber sie sind
wirtschaftlich monetär sind sie so
präsent in europa wie nie zuvor
das problem von kriegs krediten und
reparationen bindet die vereinigten
staaten an die entwicklungen nach europa
der doors plan dass huber moratorium das
sind nicht zufällig alles amerikanische
finanzspezialisten also insofern das
muss man noch mal ein bisschen
relativieren und ich will noch mal an
meine wirtschaftsexperten erinnern die
im grunde genommen
aus dieser welt wirtschaftlichen
verflechtungen die auch ein ergebnis des
ersten weltkrieges ist versuchen eine
chance zu machen da warum haben sie
nicht gewonnen warum waren sie nicht in
gewisser weise kommt der hohe preis des
krieges am ende der 20er jahre in der
weltwirtschaftskrise noch mal zurück
alle haben mit inflation zu tun und es
gibt dann unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
auf diese inflation zu reagieren aber
klar ist dass die harte sparpolitik in
vielen europäischen
nachkriegsgesellschaft dann enorme
politische und soziale kosten mit sich
gebracht hat und das hat im grunde
genommen das zeitfenster für diese
andere form der erholung abgekürzt darin
liegt die eigentliche problematik der
1928 ausbrechenden
der ausbrechenden krise aber nochmal
wenn es eine hoffnungsfrohe 1918 19 gibt
dann sind es nicht mehr die alten
europäischen mächte sondern dann sind
das wilson und lenin übrigens weit über
europa hinaus auch die inder auch die
koreaner auch die chinesischen
intellektuellen berufen sich auf diese
führer und nicht mehr andere insofern
ist es da würde ich noch mal ganz klar
sagen
vor allen dingen der beginn eines
komplizierten amerikanischen
jahrhunderts dessen ausläufer wir
vielleicht in der gegenwart erleben aber
eine hoffnungsfrohe der guten jahre der
weimarer republik war ja nur ein ganz
zweifellos gustav stresemann der ja
dennoch auch wie viele andere
demokratische führer nicht nur von den
radikalen weiten ja auch eine revision
der wasserverträge wollte in osteuropa
in osteuropa westpreußen posen etc
und wir dürfen nicht vergessen gustav
stresemann applaudiert dem
friedensvertrag von brest lied offs und
würden größer und hören geben und wir
sozusagen im frühjahr 1918 sagen wir
brauchen keine 14 punkte wir haben den
sieg im osten
das ist auch ein langer weg zur republik
der lange zeit gar nicht so einfach zu
erkennen ist aber was stresemann und
viele andere mit ihm um die mitte der
20er jahre verstehen ist wie kann man
aus der wirtschaftlichen potenz
deutschlands etwas machen um konflikte
zu überwinden
das ist ein ganz entscheidender ansatz
wenn man so will verzicht auf grenz
revisionen im westen und wirtschaftliche
verflechtungen die zumindest ein
zeitfenster geöffnet hat das dann durch
die wirtschaftskrise am ende der 20er
jahre kurz geschlossen oder das problem
war nur dass es eben so weitsichtig nach
osten nicht weil du hast das gesagt im
osten war man dann schon noch die
weitere existenz des polnischen staates
zuschuss lowak und so weiß das war alles
nicht der massen evident dass das so
bleiben sollte und wusste auch für
stress und mal nicht
und da ist also das was man auch als
diesel revanchismus das weiter treiben
das nationalistische das ist da nicht
vorbei wenn er denn diese öffnung die
nach westen geschieht dann rosten auch
geschehen wäre ich weiß nicht
dann hätte es eine echte friedens
perspektive geben können aber so
deshalb komme ich nochmal darauf zurück
dass zurückziehen von der von der usa du
hast völlig recht wirtschaftlich ist das
nicht so bedeutend aber das politische
zurückziehen ist auch ein moralisches
zurückziehen was gewesen wäre
in der dann folgenden auseinandersetzung
zwischen sowjetsystem und der
demokratisierten gesellschaften wenn die
usa noch auf der seite gestanden hätten
wage ich nicht zu beantworten sehe ich
also aber durchaus als einen katalysator
an der dann hätte eintreten können aber
das war nicht der fall
meine letzte frage geht wie immer an sie
alle wir leben ja nun heute 20 18 in
einer zeit in der manche einen neuen
großen krieg befürchten was lernen wir
denn nun aus diesen jahren 1918 19 100
jahre nach all den profile man also was
was ich besonders besorgniserregend
finde wenn man sich mit der weimarer
republik fast ist irgendwie dass man so
empfinde ich das dass man heute
eigentlich mitbekommen dass genau also
in ähnlicher weise verantwortungslos mit
demokratischen errungenschaften
umgegangen wird also sei es jetzt die
ganze berichterstattung um die mögliche
regierungsbildung sei es die
hassattacken die im internet zu finden
sind also das ist sowas wo ich merke da
sind parallelen und auch sie diese diese
invektiven kultur die man in weimar
findet also diese aggressive sprache die
die eben auch wahrscheinlich ein
einteiler ja ja die hat sprache die eben
auch ein teil dieses militärischen
konflikt oder einen reinen einen auswurf
des militärischen konfliktes war
und da sehe ich jetzt ohne die
stabilisierung das irgendwie man hat den
eindruck dass sich keiner mehr darum
kümmert dass wir auch was haben was
wirklich zu bewahren ist also das ist so
ein bisschen bleibt herr lehrer ich
glaube der blick auf er sei kann uns
doch noch mal sehr viel darüber sagen
wie gefährlich hoch emotionalisierte
politik funktioniert denn das ist das
was letztlich passiert der krieg wird
zum verbrechen und der schuldige in
anführungszeichen wird zum verbrecher
und das überdeckt dann im grunde
genommen alle anderen dinge und das hat
die politische kultur von weimar
tiefgreifend belastet das zweite mit den
deutschen wird über lange zeit nicht
gesprochen es ist eine krise der
politischen kommunikation die da im
grunde genommen geschieht die deutschen
dann auch als demütigung wahrgenommen
haben
aber ich wäre vorsichtig mit den
analogien denn wir haben heute eben doch
auch eine menge institutionen und
gremien die es damals in dieser form
nicht gab
man kann über den völkerbund sehr vieles
sagen aber man hat bei der gründung der
vereinten nationen auch aus den
problemen den schwächen den nicht
beteiligungen im völkerbund gelernt und
deshalb will ich die krisen der
gegenwart nicht gut reden aber ich wäre
vorsichtig von diesen leichten analogien
auszugehen wir brauchen analogien das
sind die glückskette unseres denkens
aber eine einfache analogie funktioniert
nicht wir sind 2018 nicht in der
situation von 1918
wir haben keinen krieg keine revolution
wir haben keine zusammenstürzenden
empire aber wir haben die phantom
probleme dieser engpass bis in die
gegenwart herkommt
ich möchte nur eins ganz kurz
hinzusetzen für mich hat der erste
weltkriegen das jetzt nicht nur besser
ist der erste weltkrieg als krieg ist
wieder einmal der beweis für die
richtigkeit des taxis von carl von
clausewitz also auch mit dem krieg der
krieg ist ein chamäleon glaubt bloß
nicht du kannst kein krieg als ordnungs
operationen führen kann du kannst einen
kurzen begrenzten krieg führen als
polizeiaktion in irgendeinem gebiet der
krieg ist ein chamäleon aus einem
kleinen krieg kann jederzeit ein ganz
anderer und viel größer werden das ist
für mich die lehre aus der damaligen
zeit und die müssen wir heutigen
politiker das müssen sie heute noch
wieder lernen
dem ist nichts hinzuzufügen frau fehler
man meine haare
ich danke ihnen sehr für ihre klugen
worte und
in liebe zuschauer danke ich für ihr
interesse
bleiben sie uns treu
[Musik]
nein